les présidents américain et chinois joba
et des années chez jean ping doivent se
parler en début d'après-midi les états
unis brandies par la voix du secrétaire
d'état américain anthony blinken la
menace de représailles si la chine et de
la russie nous n'hésiterons pas à lui
imposer des coûts a fait savoir le chef
de la diplomatie américaine la chine qui
affiche une forme de neutralité depuis
le début du conflit on écoute anthony
blinken
nous pensons que la chine a la
responsabilité en particulier d'user de
son influence auprès du président
poutine est de défendre les règles et
principes internationaux qu'elle affirme
soutenir au lieu de cela il semble que
la chine ait dans la direction opposée
en refusant de condamner cette agression
tout en cherchant à se poser en arbitre
neutre nous sommes préoccupés par le
fait qu'ils envisagent d'assister
directement la russie avec de
l'équipement militaire qu'il serait
utilisé en ukraine le président biden
doit parler au président çi demain et
lui dira clairement que la chine portera
la responsabilité pour tout acte visant
à soutenir l'agression russe